les solutions concevables euh c'est euh
la solution à deux états la solution à
un état pas de
solution finance des projets dev dire
comment pouvons-nous relancer la la
processus de paix si vous me permettez
de faire un petit peu moi j'aurais
tendance à dire les deux parties sont
incapables d'aller à la paix par
elles-même les deux parties par
elles-même hein vous avez d'abord
négocier avec qui vous avez d'un côté un
gouvernement d'extrême droite qui ne
veut pas lâcher la S Jordanie dans les
fêtes euh de l'autre côté vous avez le
Hamas on va pas négocier avec le Hamas
et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut une
mobilisation de la communauté
internationale il faut les pays arabes
les pays européens d'une certainer
manière de qui soi capable de dire aux
Israéliens et aux Palestiniens bah voilà
si vous vous asseyez autour de la même
table et bien nous nous pouvons vous
apporter ça nous pouvons vous dire les
Arabes reconstruction de du des de Gaza
les Arabes disons aux Israéliens vous
serez une part intégrante de de cette de
cette région les Européens voyez on peut
essayer pour essayer de convaincre des
gens qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas vraiment
pas envie de s'asseoir autour de la même
table de s'asseoir autour de la même
table mais pour et pour ça la France
peut agir mais ça voudrait dire qu'elle
agisse discrètement et et je crains que
ce ne soit pas un des talents principaux
de la diplomatie française